you got it I still recall that very
first game with the Sicilian here we go
the night I am avoiding the Sicilian if
I and III wouldn't want tonight to be
playing the Sicilian but i'm going to
try the sicilian against mr. teen night
sveshnikov are we going to have that
night b5 line let us see about that
maybe five most testings veticon of land
engaged bishop out so far so book Bishop
takes Knight I need to take with my pond
otherwise 95 kills me will we be seeing
c3 or c4 in this game Bishop takes
Knight the current imbalance bishop for
night exchange monster on d5 bishop move
first then castle hmm
yes let's castle if Bishop g4 Bishop e6
I don't want to exchange bishops out if
we're going to exchange I wanted to
happen on e6 let me play here and as
soon as that night moves i think i'll
run forward with a 5 b-4 ideas and if
this pond flinches then I could jump
into d4 with my night I think next
Bishop e6 we might have this advance or
not let me do this right now only after
the night moves will I do this otherwise
I'm just dropping be right now right now
timely timely timely timely so this is
not yet an open file but it could turn
out to be an open file quickly so next
up what might I want to do I might want
to let's say play f5 but my light
squares I don't know or maybe I could
look into g 6 + f5 maybe just getting my
king to AJ out of harm's way out of
potential checking points by this night
is purposeful ok this move I don't know
that that is correct because now I can
maybe be making use of this square but I
don't want to do this move just yet if I
do this move now b4 c4 I can't jump into
this square just yet if a 4 then I'll do
this let me just if I do this there's c4
and then 83 the pond exchange occurs and
this rook gets play on the a file so I
don't want to do that what I want to do
is maybe g6 and f5 or f5 right away
maybe I'd want to just do that throw my
king in the corner and pass there now
what back to your move you figure out
what to do I don't know what to do you
figure it out the other thing I could
try is 97 to challenge this night maybe
there was something better than throwing
my king in the corner I actually have a
time advantage which is wonderful if
this night moves maybe then i do before
because if the night if the night is no
longer here if i undermine this pond
then I could jump into here I think now
is the time I do
and hopefully my night could be
disruptive being on this square or at
the very least mask this queen from
seeing this night directly so that after
c4 if I jump my knight in here and in
the night is challenged I could take
this night first I think I take here
right now and then jump my knight in and
that's going to be awkward let's give it
a shot let's jump into this square again
night here I think I take this night and
I'm doing okay so okay now this is what
I was just talking about i could take
this night first i think that that's
working I think that that's working this
is a nice square though for white but
maybe I could work around it I might
also want to just keep my night right
there if this is taken i have a passed
pawn opposite color bishop ending now I
definitely want to play g6 flight square
I'm hitting the rook flight square okay
rook play here put pressure on my pawn
there's looking for made over here but
I'm not going to allow that I want my
king up however Queen here I guess I
could do this but now i'm dropping that
pound but now that's not there ok so now
i do this and if the Queen threatens to
get here i believe i play h5 in response
is this move going to be good well I
have to pretty much do that move so if
pond push I just push here this is a
very very committal mill so what do I
want to do from this position I believe
just exchanged a pair of rooks the more
I exchange I think the more that this
pond becomes valuable I can't I don't
have this move just yet okay but now
this diagonal has opened up I think now
throwing my rook on this square at some
point could turn out to be quite good
what else is there I don't think there's
anything better than doing this this
advanced is going to come I really can't
prevent it okay huh
now that's interesting looking for this
pond plush huh how do i meet that i have
a time edge maybe i could devote some
time right now to thinking of a good
plan this Bishop is doing nothing but
just defending rook here trying to get
possibilities for us pin huh well you
know what I'm doing you know what I'm
going to do this and if f5 I played g5
and keep things closed keep that F file
closed is the plan I think that this
turns out to be a good solution to this
idea that white hat of pressing forward
with f5 and also by avoiding this
exchange it limits this Bishop a little
bit more because a pond would be fixed
and on a light square so if f5 g5 I
really would like to just double and you
know what I could actually keep my queen
right where she's at and do it like this
looking to then pivot on this square so
I do this first my bishop and clean
around even the Queen getting here I
don't know that I'm really fearful of
that actually let me just do this right
now that has to be very uncomfortable
pollen is passed in my queen playing to
be 6 i think is going to be incredibly
annoying potential to just move with
check potential to maybe undermine this
Bishop the rook is going to be invading
very soon Queen B 6 pawn push deadly
threat rook to e8 is Pawn very deep
number one priority without a doubt I
actually didn't have to defend them
indirectly defending it with this Bishop
move look up and then maybe even g4
ideas okay now with this I can't
undermine the bishops position but what
i can do is maybe look
to and do some weakness against this
king I think maybe queen here we make
progress in this position actually I
would love to get a rope right here i
think that would he be even better and i
can shoot for it I want to remove this
Queen I want to challenge this Queen so
I'm threatening right now rook f4 to f2
again keeping in mind that there is this
pin that I could be having is the Queen
go and the King go in the corner if he
does then there's potential for back
rank mates okay that that was minced
that was what i was saying for a while
now that Bishop deformer was something
that I always had but my opponent was
down on time alright let's back up flip
that board as veteran cop Sicilian so so
far so book night for Bishop exchange
you'll either see c3 or c4 Bishop g5
Bishop e2 ok we didn't see it in the
game but again keep in mind Bishop e2 I
believe Bishop e6 is needed you can't
just go Bishop takes Queen takes because
this night is all the more powerful
white can rely upon that night so much
easier and white would then be one step
closer to getting into a good night
versus a bad Bishop type of position so
castles rookie a rookie one I don't know
about rookie one maybe it's better to
just follow through with the night move
Knight c2 maybe actually instead of the
bishop move as soon as I castle excuse
me right here c3 Bishop g5 maybe it's
best to just immediately go with night c
2 and then a 4 i'm not certain to the
move order I'm familiar with these moves
that are played by white and the moves
that are played by black but I'm not
certain about the timing of them that's
one thing it's it's one to know how
these are good these are good moves but
the time in which they're played
not so sure about those okay so we get
into this position B 3 I was a bit happy
to see be three because then i started
to cd4 as a welcome or you know a nice
home for my night so maybe b3 is
slightly off and I guess I'm just kind
of passing with my king may be better as
g6 but I just kind of wanted to see he's
playing that practical right there blitz
game just kind of wanted to pass I
wasn't sure what to do ok we have that
exchange I jump into d4 now I'm able to
take on this square and having the pond
recapture and fill this hole then it's
much different I don't have to deal with
the piece there I don't have to worry
about this pawn on d6 as much and now
this is very difficult I think black is
just standing better now I really don't
know what to do here for why I don't
know what to suggest quite difficult
constantly having to work around this
pond c3 is a pivot point for my pieces
rook here even if it's taken its just
creating a more mobility for my bishop
it's still being watched over by my
bishop and it still remains past so I
think this is certainly a position to
avoid I don't know if I gave you some
way to kind of sneak out of it from here
once we're in the opposite color bishop
ending ok good game as usual mr. t night